[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire pour ce débat sur la sphère
didier raoul tincques plus vous allez me
dire non pas tout à fait personnellement
je refuse d'animer un débat sur
l'efficacité de tel ou tel traitement
médical que ce soit comment soigner le
cancer ou comment soigner le grenat
virus je n'ai jamais fait n'ayant aucune
compétence scientifique les médecins que
j'inviterai pourrait me raconter
n'importe quoi je demande l'apercevrait
même pas mais la polémique autour du
professeur raoul dépasse tout cela elle
oppose depuis quatre mois ce qu'ils
croient en rajouter ceux qui n'y crois
pas c'est devenu une véritable guerre de
religion alors on ne peut pas débattre
de l'existence de dieu ni de la foi ou
des miracles on y croit ou on n'y croit
pas mais on peut débattre des saintes
écritures c'est ce que nous allons faire
avec un pro et un anti raul puisque la
france désormais se divise entre pro et
anti raul mais deux invités ne sont pas
médecin mais ils se sont intéressés à ce
que dit didier rahout le premier c'est
raphaël liogier il est philosophe et
sociologue professeur à l'institut
d'études politiques d'aix-en-provence
vous êtes l'auteur de sacrés médecine
histoire est de venir d'un sanctuaire de
la raison avec jean baubérot et de
l'horreur du vide critique de la raison
industrialiste qui paraîtra à la rentrée
aux liens qui libèrent et qui parlera
notamment de la polémique autour de
didier raoult
j'ajoute que vous êtes membre du comité
d'éthique de liège chu de marseille de
didier raoul tu es que vous avez
participé à la rédaction d'un rapport à
la demande du professeur raoul sur
comment articuler recherché soins en
temps de pandémie
un rapport qui devrait être disponible
bientôt et sur lequel tout le monde se
précipitera alors pour vous qui défendez
le travail du professeur raoul quelle
est la morale de toute cette polémique
en deux mots raphaël liogier pour moi la
morale de cette polémique c'est
justement qu'au delà d'une querelle qui
a l'air d'être une querelle
scientifique empirique même vous dire et
c'est une querelle qui est beaucoup plus
profonde
c'est une querelle qui relève de comment
j'allais dire delà de la perte de
crédibilité de la science et du
transformation une transformation des
grands paradigmes scientifique
d'ailleurs lorsqu'on parle par exemple
de 2 des essais en double aveugle
randomisée toutes ces choses là on parle
d'une méthode qui est supposé pouvoir
toucher le trouver le médicament pur le
médicament absolue et puis d'un autre
côté on a une méthodologie qui est quand
même aussi une méthodologie de
méthodologie de didier rahout qui est en
fait une méthodologie plus par
tâtonnement plus relativisme où on
cherche à soigner on regarde ce qui
marche ce qui ne marche pas il n'y a pas
cet arrière-fond paradoxalement qui
serait un arrière fond presque religieux
justement dans les religieux ne sont pas
du côté de ceux que l'on croirait les
religieux sont plus dans cette espèce de
donné au positivisme cette espèce de
rationalisme vous savez il y avait le
philosophe hegel qui disait que tout le
réel et rationnelle et bien je crois que
les que les antilles raout sont les
hégélien qui défendent cette espèce
d'idéal industriali du contrôle de
recherche de la vérité du médicament
parfait et c'est alors que dans un sens
la société l'a déjà dépassées et c'est
ça la querelle le sens de la querelle au
sens le plus profond du terme
à mon sens et je crois que c'est ça ces
deux imaginaires au fond qui
s'affrontent deux paradigmes surprise
face à raphaël liogier il y à olivier
berruyer le fondateur du site les crises
spécialisés
dans la déconstruction des propagandes
olivier berruyer qui a rédigé une étude
très critique du travail du professeur
raoul temps s'appuyant sur ses
publications et sur ses déclarations
pour vous c'est quoi la morale de toute
cette polémique que ligne et bien
écoutez pas déjà premier point je me
place pas du tout dans un corps je
dirais anti raouraoua était aussi un des
seuls à faire un travail très
intéressant sur les séquelles à faire
passer des scanners à toutes les
personnes qui étaient atteintes et ça
s'est vraiment bien il fait un beau
travail là dessus il ne s'agit pas
d'être pro ou anti raoult justement un
avortement ou prou aux sciences et en
tout cas des principes fondamentaux de
la science ça c'est ça c'est sûr je
dirais de la morale de cette histoire
moi je m'agite en débattra avec avec la
paye que j'ai plus tard mais sur ce
problème et moi je dirais c'est que en
fait en devient une société de
l'affrontement
chacun essaie de se positionner contre
quelque chose
d'ailleurs beaucoup plus que pour
quelque chose c'est quand même quelque
chose de très intéressant
les grands médias pouces acer pour
essayer d'avoir du buzz duplique un
point c'est de vendre un peu plus de
papier mais au final on s'aperçoit que
ça pousse la population à n'ont pas
utilisé son esprit critique pour essayer
pas de découvrir la vérité pour 400
rapprocher et d'avoir des bases pour
discuter tous ensemble mais ça peut
fanatisés un nombre assez important de
personnes qui se sert finalement
l'esprit critique possible d'asseoir
leurs certitudes plutôt que de douter et
la science à ses doutes et toujours à
russell disait très justement ne soyez
jamais sûr de rien en tout cas tout est
raisonnablement ont pas non plus un sur
doute mais qui empêchera aussi
d'atteindre la vérité pour moi c'est
vraiment ça cette histoire de passion
très étrange alors qu on pourrait
débattre tranquillement du sujet un être
que j'espère qu'on va revenir au réel et
qu'on va sortir de cette espèce de pot
de vérité orwellienne où chacun s'est
inventé une réalité dans laquelle il vit
et quand on vit dans des réalités
différentes euros peut plus communiquer
alors comment son camp mais tout de même
par ce que vous reprochez vous
olivier berruyer au travail du
professeur raoul parce que là vous avez
dit que vous n'étiez pas un anti raul et
que vous le voulez admiriez pour un
certain nombre de choses néanmoins vous
avez été très très sévère sur sur à la
fois ses publications et ses
déclarations concernant le qu'ovide 19
depuis le quasiment le début de cette
crise alors ré pour résumé pour ceux qui
n'auraient pas vu lu votre enquêtes
minutieuses et détaillées dans les
crises qu'est ce que vous lui reprochez
là on peut résumer le résumé encore
beaucoup plus facilement lorsque ce que
c'est vraiment qu'on peut reprocher à
route c'est d'avoir cessé de faire de la
science et de la médecine sur la
politique rcsa c'est qu'en fait il a
politisé
un sujet qui devrait rester un sujet un
sujet scientifique
il a abandonné les principes
fondamentaux de la médecine au moment où
on en avait le plus besoin pour essayer
de montrer qu'il avait raison lancés çà
fondamentalement c'est qu'il a
transformé il ya chu de marseille en
centre mondial du lobbying de la
chloroquine encore à fait logique verdir
un restaurant non mais c'est bien oui
t'as tony cherche qui marche qui marche
pas non les ja cherche à montrer coûte
que coûte que la chloroquine ça marche
point final c'est systématiquement une
déconstruction de toute étude qui du
contraire c'est pas sous silence certain
nombre d'autres études qui montrent
certains dangers du traitement mais en
avoir des études complètement bidon ou
comme celle du professeur période on
avait fait un putsch magnificat et au
regard des professeurs peron super
l'étude a été retirée comme 7027
quelques jours après on n'a pas parlé
des os et cacher la vérité aux gens
pressés faire croire que la chloroquine
ça marche alors j'ai montré ça en détail
on vraiment les publications
scientifiques
je peux le faire à l'antenne ce sera un
peu long les gens peuvent regarder mais
je peux citer peut-être deux petites
exemple d'où part cette histoire la
chloroquine rav oudi un début février
il faut écouter les chinois c'est
vraiment les rois de la virologie les
chinoises utilisent la chloroquine bon
et très bien d'autres livres utilisés
chloroquine après au bout d'un mois
qu'il nous faut utiliser les dropkick
leur hawkins est proche mais c'est pas
tout à fait la même chose des chinois
l'utilisent pas l'hydroxyde rockin après
il dit on va rajouter un antibiotique là
pour que ça marche mieux dans les
guidelines chinoise il est marqué si
vous l'utilisez la chloroquine
n'utilisait surtout pas d'antibiotiques
c'est dangereux et est donc au bout d'un
moment on se retrouve à voir ou qui nous
dit un moment faut écouter les chinois
qui était le contraire de ce que font
les chinois et je vais citer un deuxième
exemple qui pour moi peut-être signe
blême une étude qui montrait que les
plus rock in a semblé un peu dangereuse
raoult a fait un petit papier en réponse
en disant non c'est pas vrai c'est pas
dangereux et pour faire ça il cite une
troisième étude dans l'étude dit il
prend la chloroquine pas dangereuse
c'est le résultat de notre étude
pourrait dire très bien mais quand vous
premier l'étude ce qui est citée par as
où il ya une suite ses marques et
virgule par contrat si vous mettez à
l'antibiotique donc si vous faites le
protocole raoult
c'est très dangereux ça augmente la
mortalité c'est quand même très bizarre
d'avoir sous le nez une étude qui dit
protocole est dangereux pour faire
croire aux gens que votre hôte open
n'est pas dangereux merci ça la méthode
raoult en fait mais ça se comprend très
bien parce que c'est plus de la science
il n'y a pas de débat scientifique comme
la biologie 90% des scientifiques voit
très bien que ça ne marche pas avec un
gros problème méthodologique
mais évidemment il ya un problème aussi
médiatique essaie de faire croire que
messi regarder ça divise les sont pas
très divisé les scientifiques à
comprendre quelqu'un qui a un doctorat
en théologie en biochimie qui connait la
science il voit très bien qui après vos
problèmes évidemment c'est pareil à
l'étranger lire tous les chasseurs de
fausses sciences ont descendu ces
travaux la rafale des objets oui ben
jabr était alors ya plusieurs choses la
première chose la première chose c'est
que c'est que regarder dans un sens mon
interlocuteur a donné raison à ce que
j'ai dit au début j'ai dit qu'il faut
que que raoult de fonctionner par
tâtonnement dit qu'au départ il et il
faut suivre ce que font les chinois et
puis après il a changé ces dosages il a
changé la nature même du produit passant
de la chloroquine à
l'hydrochlorothiazide justement parce
que raout fonctionne de façon
pragmatique et la science a toujours été
pragmatique la science médicale en
particulier la médecine c'est pas de la
physique théorique
moi j'ai un peu étudié l'évolution de
l'épistémologie médical et ce n'est pas
la physique théorique c'est justement un
fonctionnement presque artisanal où on
passe du soin à la recherche de la
recherche aux soins et bien comment dire
raout il est dense est dans cette
logique là c'est pour ça que ce qui
privilégie c'est ce qu'il appelle les
études observationnelles d'une part et
d'autre d'autre part le les allers et
retours avec le soin et donc avec ces
allers retours il a progressivement fait
évoluer son traitement ce qui prouve
bien que justement il n'est pas dans
cette espèce de deux postures
complètement
monologique parlant avec lui même et
seulement avec son équipe ne sait
seulement que il a progressivement
évolué mais dans son travail dans le
rapport aux soins avec les patients et
je vous rappelle que c'est quand même le
plus grand nombre de le plus grand
nombre de personnes testées en france
par proportion des habitants
c'est à marseille donc il avait une
énorme une énorme comme un énorme vivier
pour cette étude opérationnelle et il a
fait évoluer petit à petit à petit pour
arriver à un traitement qu'ils soient le
plus efficaces possible mais il faut
quand même je voudrais dire 1 2 une
deuxième chose
une deuxième chose c'est que le ce que
proposait didier rahout ce ne peut pas
être ne peut pas être limité à la
question l'hydro que l'euro qui je crois
que là on essaie c'est un peu l'arbre
qui cache la forêt on essaie de cacher
un certain nombre d'erreurs et d'erreurs
je pense qu'ils sont d'ailleurs
politique pas une question de théories
de théorie du complot mais d'erreurs
qu'on était des hommes politiques c'est
que ce que prenait didia août bien
au-delà de la question de l'hydro plus
rock il s'était de pester
systématiquement tout le monde sait ça
et c'est ce qui a été fait à marseille
on peut lui reprocher ce qu'on veut vous
assure c'est ce qui a été fait à
marseille autant qu'il a pu le faire
avec les moyens qui étaient étaient les
siens systématiquement tout le monde et
ensuite de mettre à l'écart voire en
quarantaine des individus qui étaient
testés positifs et seulement eux et
seulement eux et ensuite les soigner
quel que soit le niveau de leur maladie
et celui avec toutes les précautions
c'est à dire pas même lorsqu'ils sont
asymptomatiques et avec toutes les
précautions les précautions possibles en
utilisant effectivement
l'hydrochlorothiazide mélange diderot
qui n'hésiteront missiles mais en
faisant comme vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs
aussi mon interlocuteur l'a dit en
faisant des scanners en faisant tout ce
qui a fait rire y compris inde électro
cardiogramme systématique moi j'y suis
passé donc j'ai j'ai eu un
électrocardiogramme tout le monde a eu
alors que j'étais asymptomatique et donc
en prenant toutes les précautions
donc c'était une méthodologie d'ensemble
de gestion de la crise et deuxième point
est le troisième point avec lequel je
serais d'accord je pense est pas
complètement avec mon interlocuteur le
troisième point c'est que oui il ya eu
politisation
mais je ne suis pas certain que ce soit
de la part de raout il est une
politisation
je crois qu'il ya eu politisation de
l'extérieur
parce que la seule chose qu on faisait
raout si vous écoutez ce qu'il dit en
dehors de sa gouaille de son esprit de
son caractère un peu un peu direct où il
a pu se laisser aller à dire des choses
que c'était une petite gripette etc
je parle pas de ça je viens parce que du
point de vue scientifique par contre là
c'était quelqu'un de très sérieux
je veux dire que il a été politisée
justement parce que ce qu'ils
proposaient ce n'était pas seulement la
question diderot plus rock'n c'était une
stratégie d'ensemble qui était opposé en
fait au confinement systématique dont on
ne sait pas encore aujourd'hui si ce
confinement général a été bon on ne sait
même pas s'il a sauvé les vies on ne
sait même pas si dans ce sens inverse
ils n'auraient pas finalement sacrifié
des vies quand on regarde des sociétés
comme la société coréenne qui n'a pas
pratiqué le confinement systématique
mais au contraire qui a pratiqué se
proposer comme comme méthodologie
générale de gestion de la crise didier
route c'est-à-dire le leu leu leu leu
leu tests systématiques
la mise à l'écart de ce qui sont testés
et le fait de les soigner mais ça ça
réduit effectivement la circulation du
virus
donc je crois quelque chose de très
rationnel de très pragmatique mais sans
cette espèce d'imaginaire qui consiste à
chercher le médicament parfait parce que
pendant qu'on cherche le médicament
parfait mais on finit par sacrifier des
vies sous prétexte d'avoir une sorte de
vision pure de ce qui se serait passé
par lille fourches caudines la médecine
n'a que très rarement fonctionné comme
ça en matière de virus en manière de
bactériologie n'a pas fonctionné comme
ça d'ailleurs avec avec par exemple avec
le sida était effroyable et beaucoup
plus effroyable en termes de nombre de
morts de létalité que le que le
coronavirus pourquoi est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui on a été obsédé par ça
pourquoi est-ce que c'est rentrer dans
le débat
je crois que c'est pas qui dira août
qu'il faut interroger c'est pourquoi est
ce que didier rahout a été le prétexte
de cela je crois surtout de cette
politisation olivier berruyer
il y aurait beaucoup de choses à dire on
s'amuse on sait les marseillais ont pas
été mis du tout en quarantaine en trois
mois ce que parce que vous dites
évidemment pour arrêter une épidémie
comme la corée est un très bon exemple
il faut essayer de tester au maximum dès
le début nous on n'a pas testé au
maximum des débuts un peu plus à
marseille et un qu'ailleurs puisque
façon moment il fallait tester et didier
raoult qui disait partout qu'il y aurait
moins de morts que ce que d'accidents
trottinette que tout ça n'était pas bien
grave que c'était rigolo quand même a
rien à qui est roi chez moi qui
me dire c'était s'attaquer au moment où
il fallait le faire on l'a pas fait
effectivement c'est plus problématique
après quand on finit par voir des
millions de personnes contaminées de
faire de faire ça si non vous ne rêvez
pas aller justement allez allez traiter
mais par rapport à ce qu'a dit raphaël
logis est ce que quand même on peut
essayer d d'accord sur le fait
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas de preuves
cliniques suffisante pour dire qu' il ya
une efficacité clinique et une sécurité
d'emploi suffisante de un lead roxy
chloroquine terreau cycloclean pape à
idron chloroquine comme comme vous le
dites dans la prise en charge du co vide
est ce qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui au
moins on ne sait pas si ça marche enfin
lionel une pose une question si c'était
pour voir si on a moins sa dette
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas si ça marche
alors alors marcher alors chercher trois
choses à dire monsieur la première ça il
n'y a pas eu quarantaine à marseille
mégalithes est systématique pour la
bonne raison que le quotidien ou ne
disposent pas de la force de police ne
sont pas des fois de la puissance de
l'état pour déclarer une quarantaine et
pour imposer la quarantaine à des gens
il peut seulement les soigner dans la
mesure de son pouvoir est seulement le
pouvoir médical
donc ça c'est une première chose donc
évidemment il y avait 40 m pour rafa
luxe d'une décision politique
c'est justement ce qu'il critique b sur
les personnes évidemment testée positive
ensuite sur la question sur la question
de la delà de la dangerosité du produit
alors il ya une différence entre
dangerosité efficacité je pense que les
preuves d'efficacité je veux dire
d'efficacité absolue du produit ne sont
pas encore là c'est vrai que c'est là
les seuls la seule possibilité pour
avoir une preuve formelle de
l'efficacité du produit ça serait
d'avoir des études en double aveugle
randomisée etc
par contre la preuve selon la ce que
l'on sait aujourd'hui
avec le recul sur sur sept ce médicament
qui a été en circulation libre pendant
des années c'est qu'il n'est pas
dangereux
si l'on prend un certain nombre de
précautions précautions qui ont été
prises
ça c'est le premier point le deuxième
point c'est que encore une fois les
études observationnelles et les études
qui ont été menées
ali a chu sur des milliers de patients
montrent qu'il y à une réduction de la
charge virale je sais qu'après on a dit
oui mais il y a des billets etc
il ya peut-être des biens mais en
attendant on a une létalité si on prend
des précautions qui n'existe pas et pas
la certitude mais enfin une
approximation une approximation de pas
de certitude mais une approximation d'un
traitement qui réduit la charge virale
et qui permet au moins au début de la
maladie de d'empêcher de passer à un
autre stade
il me semble que les statistiques alors
je sais je pense que vous serez pas
d'accord avec ça parce que c'est
aujourd'hui fait l'objet la polémique
mais les statistiques aujourd'hui en
terme de mortalité de personnes
infectées semble intérieur à marseille
chez les jantes ou pas qui ont été
traités dans le service de didier et des
trois quatre mille personnes qui y sont
passés au reste de la france donc pour
l'instant
ces statistiques sont effectivement
sujette à caution mais moi je crois que
didier out a eu raison de prendre ce
risque
pour la bonne raison qu'il savait qu'en
prenant les précautions au moins il ne
faisait pas courir un risque médical
négatif aux gens qu'ils soignent et est
donc le seul risque possible le seul à
seul peuple un seul comment dire le seul
ça pouvait se mesurer qu'en termes
davantage pour lui d'après ce qu'il ce
qu'il savait je bouge je crois que c'est
assez prouvé de ce point de vue là
olivier berruyer ce qui est prouvé c'est
que la pharmacovigilance indique déjà
celle d'essayer la chloroquine et de
sans effets secondaires très grave
en tout cas c'est c'est parce que vous
dites ou les au jour d'aujourd'hui est
strictement pas la moindre preuve que
non seulement le médicament sauvent des
vies mais même évidemment qui réduit la
charge virale ce que la fois ce que des
cités tout à l'heure en disant
qu'aujourd'hui il n'ya pas l'efficacité
clinique démontré c'est une phrase de
sanofi 1 qui a été diffusé il ya une
quinzaine de jours à tous les médecins
belges je répète à ce jour il n'existe
pas de preuves cliniques suffisantes
pour tirer une conclusion quelconque sur
l'efficacité clinique et la sécurité
d'emploi de diderot xi chloroquine dans
la prise en charge du comité r que le
fabricant de la chloroquine vous dit on
sait pas si ça marche et on sait pas si
ça fait pas du dga est en moi je trouve
formidable qu'on ait réussi à faire en
france un centre mondial de lobbying de
la chloroquine qui arrive à être
beaucoup plus ultra que le propre
fabricant d'ailleurs en employant des
méthodes que les pires la bonne
utiliserait pas moi c'est de promouvoir
leurs médicaments
hier c'est ça le problème et par rapport
à ce que vous dites alors vivre il ya qu
à tâtonner machin moi j'ai envie de dire
mais en fait les marseillais c'est pas
des macaques
il ya c'est pas des bidules sur les
quais la tiens je respecte de la poudre
pour voir ce qui se passe et ça marche
ça marche pas flûte ça en tue testons ça
pendant un certain temps et puis si
finalement il n'y a pas trop de morts
peut-être qu'on pourra tester sur des
animaux va dire il ya eu des tests qui
ont été fait d'ailleurs il ya trois
semaines sur des singes la chloroquine
avec l'antibiotique sans antibiotiques
au début avant après la maladie ça ne
l'a pas d'efficacité sur les singes à ce
jour c'est tout ça à mon pays aucun
tâtonnements le thé seul tâtonnements de
la dora où c est ce que la chloroquine
fall a donné à 8 heures le matin ou à
midi est-ce qu'il faut mettre à 600 mg
ou 550 c'est sûrement pas de dire est-ce
que telle autre moule et tout ça marche
parce que la percée quand ça marche
parce que le plasma ça marche rcsa
tâtonner c'est ne pas respecter les
principes fondamentaux c'est à prendre
des risques pour la santé parce que
c'est pas du tout un médicament à moteur
après que les 36 chloroquine s'attaque
le coeur un peu mais sauf que le comité
attac le coeur aussi
et quand vous mettez l'azithromycine ces
attaques le coeur lui aussi beaucoup
donc c'est pour ça qu'il ya des
personnes qui meurent de ce traitement
là comme l'a signalé la
pharmacovigilance donc après la méthode
c'est pas des trucs qui sont faits pour
embêter
qui sont des règles administratives qui
empêchent de soigner des gens où la
ville avait très bien vivre seul et je
vais directement le mieux la rolls c'est
d'avoir des essais cliniques randomisés
en double aveugle mais pour faire un
essai clinique randomisé en double
aveugle il faut à moi mais c'est pas un
truc qui prend huit ans et demi
elle est d'ailleurs justement les
anglais l'ont fait n'ont pas vu
d'efficacité qui est arrêté à détester
l'hydroxyde chloroquine pour aller se
concentrer sur d'autres sur d'autres
médicaments parce que quand vous dites
vous savez il n'ya pas y'a pas l'effet
négatif alors si on prend les plus
grands de précaution on fait des essais
qu'on fait des électrocardiogrammes trop
les jours il n'y a peut-être pas
beaucoup d'effets graves j'entends bien
mettant toute cette histoire
en plus d'avoir attenté à des principes
fondamentaux de la médecine et je répète
un moment n'aurait plus besoin est
surtout ça nous fait perdre du temps
parce que à la fin du fin on a un
faisceau maintenant de preuves j'espère
qu'on trouvera la solution contraire moi
j'ai pas bien que ça marche 4 l'euro qui
ne m'en fous rires je veux vraiment je
ne suis ni pour ni contre mais vrai il
ya tout un faisceau qui montrent que ça
marche probablement pas parce que la
pharmacocinétique vous dis qu'on
n'atteint pas les deux suffisante dans
le corps pour que ça puisse marcher on
l'a testé sur des singes ça marche pas
on l'a même testé sur des anglais ça
marche pas et il est est sûre en soit
les marseillais sont en termes de
méthodologie ridicule ce soit n'y a
jamais de groupe contrôle dont pouvait
pas savoir si ça marche ou ça marche pas
donc du poil ses compères du temps
d'accord si une deuxième vague qui vient
l'automne on va l'attaquer exactement
comme la première il n'y a pas de
traitement
donc on n'a pas testé la carte 0 on
n'était pas assez testé le lopinavir
enfin il y en a 50 des molécules
aujourd'hui testé par gonesse
on n'a parlé que d'une on a mis tous les
oeufs dans le même panier on doit avoir
la moitié des essais cliniques de la
planète sur cette molécule là c'est
quand même sidérant il n'y a pas de n'y
a pas de sécurité des patients et c'est
que c'est pas mis au coeur de l'auteur
du sujet
moi j'ai pas envie la parole est à
raphaël liogier nous on a quatre minutes
et voilà je crois je crois que vous
engagez vous savez bien que la plupart
des essais aujourd'hui justement se font
pas sur ne sont pas focalisés sur la
clarté ils sont focalisés sur les autres
ça danse ça n'enlève rien à dire que
didier la 150e n'enlève rien s'ils sont
faits par ailleurs non mais non mais non
mais ça n'enlève rien aux essais qui
sont faits par ailleurs je ne vois pas
pourquoi lusage l'usagé contrôlé de la
chloroquine dans certains contextes
empêche ferait perdre du temps je vois
pas pourquoi d'ailleurs je vois pas la
logique dans ce que vous me dites c'est
à dire bonjour et moi je suis
effectivement j'ai continué je vais vous
montre messieurs logique quand tous les
médias quand tous les médias ont dit
pendant des semaines la chloroquine
c'est génial eh bien laissez discovery
quand il allait aux gens venez on va
vous tester leur haine des hivers déjà
étant dit j'en veux pas du tout moi je
veux du henné chloroquine et je veux pas
placebo donc vous avez empêché les
recrutements mais regardez il ya plein
d'articles de presse qui ont expliqué ça
très bien
je pense que c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça ce qui s'est passé avec
l'essai discovery je crois que là vous
ça vous simplifier ce qui s'est passé
avec l'essai discovery par ailleurs il
ya toute une série d'essais qui ont été
effectués avec des deux qui sont plus du
double supérieure à celles qui sont qui
sont utilisés à ali a chu a lieu à 10 h
u2 alliage de marseille / concept
concernant sanofi excusez moi que vous
avez dit beaucoup de choses donc il faut
que je concernant sanofi sur le fait que
ce ne soit pas conclusif malawi d'accord
avec sanofi bien sûr c'est ce que j'ai
dit dès le début en tâtonnements et mais
par contre c'est sur la question de la
sécurité quand vous dites qu'il y à sept
morts jusqu'à preuve du contraire il n'y
a pas du tout de certitude que c'est
cette mort soit due à un effet direct de
la chloroquine et et est par ailleurs
les seuls effets qui ont pu être
observés ils ont été relativement
faibles et ils peuvent être contrôlés
ils peuvent être contrôlée justement par
des dosages et ils peuvent être
contrôlés dans ne justement en utilisant
pas dans certains cas extrêmes la
chloroquine donc évidemment ça veut dire
c'est un médicament qui a des effets des
effets qui sont forts et donc comme si
ce sont des idées qui font fort il faut
prendre un certain nombre de précautions
précautions pour été prise donc je vais
vous dire vous dit ce qu'il fait à
marseille c'est c ces vagues c'est pas
sérieux etc
j'ai quand même des milliers de gens qui
sont passés par un parent par arias eu
des centaines qui ont été soignés alias
jeu donc on dispose malgré tout on a
beau dire ce qu'on veut on dispose je
veux dire par l'observation de paix d
évolution de ces malades on peut le
comparer ça on peut les comparer
statistiquement avec ce qui s'est passé
dans d'autres hôpitaux
on n'a pas encore c'est pas encore
conclusive mais il me semble que cela va
plutôt dans le sens du protocole qui
était utilisé à marseille alors après on
peut dire ce qu'on veut sur sanofi sano
dit sanofi vous savez très bien que
c'est absolument pas une preuve un
laboratoire peut raconter absolument ce
qu'il veut c'est pas eux qui sont
scientifiques même s'il paye des
scientifiques
par ailleurs ça pourrait être d'autre
intérêt à ce que sanofi fait aussi
d'autres d'autres mais d'autres
médicaments et ça serait pas si rentable
que ça pour sanofi devant diderot
chloroquine qui est un médicament qui
coûtent 30 40 50 60 fois moins cher qu'à
peu près tous les autres ils sont
revendus proposait donc je veux pas
rentrer dans la question de théories du
complot vos arguments sur le laboratoire
qui dit que etc soit un bon argument on
va faire une pause et puis on reprend ce
débat avec olivier berruyer et raphaël
liogier juste après ça
[Musique]
on reprend ce débat sur la sphère didier
raoul tu avec raphaël liogier qui est
membre du comité d'éthique de lier à chu
de marseille et qui a participé à la
rédaction du rapport qui devrait sortir
bientôt qui a été demandé par didier
rahout lui-même et olivier berruyer
le fondateur du site les crises qui a
fait une étude minutieuse et très
critique à l'égard d' du travail de
didier raoul je rappelle que ça dépasse
un débat entre médecins ya un débat
scientifique ni médicale
chacun vous vous êtes intéressé à ce
qu'a dit ce qu'a écrit sk publiés didier
raoul tu alors justement vous l'avez dit
olivier berruyer didier rahout n'a pas
fait année saic tels qu'on les dit
sérieux dans ce domaine randomisée en
double aveugle etc etc
il aurait pu le faire dit vous ça prend
un mois mais en même temps on observe
que personne ne l'a fait non plus en
france personne n'a fait cet essai à
chaque fois qu'on nous a dit si si si il
ya quelqu'un qui est en train de le
faire si on n'a jamais eu les résultats
sauf s'est aperçu qu'en fait ce n'est
pas exactement le protocole de didier
raoul qui était testé tout ça a beaucoup
accréditer l'idée d'un complot contre
raul contre son traitement
alors certains y ont vu la raison que
qu'invoquait qu'évoquait raphaël liogier
à savoir le fait que ce traitement pas
cher et que donc on n'aurait pas voulu
que ce traitement pas cher pour pouvoir
privilégier un hypothétique traitement
très très cher qui viendraient qui
viendrait de qui donnerait le jour en un
jour mais enfin pour vous pourquoi est
ce qu'on n'a pas fait d'essais cliniques
sérieux en france
sur ce mais sur ce traitement oui très
rapidement très rapidement en effet
indiqué roy pas fait baisser un décès
sérieux et pointe ce qui a même pas fait
baisser les gaulois parce qu'il ya un
problème de légalité par rapport à ce
qu'il a fait qui s'apparentent à des
essais cliniques sauvages qui sont
pénalement réprimés et la nacelle est en
train de s'en occuper justement on voit
que les autorités ont été totalement
lexington laxiste dans cette histoire
pourquoi il a passé lui c'est très
simple parce que quand vous faites un
essai vous avez la preuve que ça marche
ou ça ne marche pas donc en fait ce
qu'il a fait à raul ça a été refusé de
faire la méthode qui allait apporter une
preuve de ces propos parce qu'évidemment
il sait très bien que ça va ça fait un
siècle vous savez quand vous sort là la
chloroquine en tout cas la quinine c'est
un dérivé des gens là 118 en expliquer
que ça soigner la grippe
évidemment ça soit ne pas du tout la
grippe à chaque période en ressources ce
traitement l'a donc didier raoult je
comprend très bien pourquoi qui fait pas
de la science il fait de la politique
donc il n'allait pas faire le truc qui
allaient montrer potentiellement qu'ils
avaient tort pourquoi on n'a pas fait
ailleurs si on essaye de le faire c'est
laisser discovery en europe mais qui
marche très mal parce qu'ils avaient du
mal à recruter et pour les raisons que
j'ai évoquées tout à l'heure regardez ya
plus dans un type de prêt ce qui
explique ça très bien ce qu'ils sont pas
les patients voulait dans la clape
l'euro qui n'est pas les pas d'autres
choses
le grand palais où discovery c'est que
ce sioniste européen pierre kolyé de
dire on va se mobiliser en france pour
avoir la vérité en l ou alors va faire
un truc en europe avec les allemands et
les italiens et les spikes va être
génial au final il n'y a que le
luxembourg qui nous a rejoint
je crois qu'il y en ai dit madame de +19
le truc est complètement ridicule
un maquereau nous a promis les résultats
pour le 13 mai donc et binbin chevaucher
le tigre donc ça devrait pas tarder à
arriver quand même mais par contre on
voit que peut-être un effet du bac si je
ne sais pas les anglais eux ont réussi à
faire cet essai à un recovery qui a
montré une efficacité d'un d'une dose
double de chloroquine c'était très drôle
que le raf est de loger les repris cet
argument là qu'ils étaient même très
étonnant
les gens disent eh ben non regardez
c'est pas bien les gens ont testé le
double de la beuze c'est pour ça que ça
marche pas enfin je veux dire on n'a pas
des comble du ridicule sur cette affaire
et il ya eu il y avait un dessin qui
était prévu par le chu d'angers
également je me souviens je l'aimais
d'annoncer dans cette émission en disant
voilà on va savoir
c'est pas la peine de s'écharper entre
croyants et non-croyants trop rajouté en
tira août
il suffit d'attendre les résultats du
chu d'angers
qu'est-il devenu un échec lamentable
c'est un échec lamentable du gouverneur
on est bien d'accord il n'y a pas de
pilotage la crau et pourquoi emmanuel
macron dans ce cas là va rendre visite
au professeur raoul tu sais pour pas se
couper de tous les français qui à ce
moment là se croient au traitement du
professeur raoul c'est de la démagogie
je parle puisque mate antisystème comme
il le dit mais il va donc y avoir des
anti système et puis avec tous et
antisystème 1 ils discutent entre eux et
c'est lamentable raconte j'avais alors
moi un pur première chose je ne vois pas
pourquoi ça sera un argument ridicule de
dire qu'on a mis le double de la dose
vous savez bien ce que veut dire
d'ailleurs le mot le mot médicaments
pharmakon en grec ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que c'est à la fois ceux
qui soignent et ce qui empoisonne
donc ça veut dire que le dosage en
médecine jusqu'à preuve du contraire
c'est une variable fondamentale
donc c'est une variable absolument
fondamental c'est pas un détail c'est
pas du tout rigolo
le fait de mettre le double de la dose
ça peut être être complètement
contre-productif
donc c'est pas si c'est une bonne ou ni
vos gardes
premièrement j'ai premièrement vous ai
nommé nommé ne vous énervez pas ne vous
énervez pas je veux dire vous savez très
bien que si vous prenez si vous prenez
même de l'aspirine vous pouvez tuer
quelqu'un avec de l'aspirine en
augmentant les dosages encore plus avec
de doliprane donc donc ne vous savez
bien que la question vous êtes d'accord
avec moi que la question du dosage c'est
par une question importante est que d'en
dire le double c'est quand même pas rien
surtout si vous même vous prétendez que
c'est un médicament qui est sensiblement
et délicat à manier c'est ce que vous
dites donc si vous en mettez le double
évidemment je crois que c'est un c'est
quand même un sacré biais donc
premièrement deuxièmement je trouve
intéressant cet argument ce que ce que
vous essayez de faire là c'est de dire
que didier rahout c'est de la politique
quand je ne vois pas en quoi didier
rahout fais de la politique mais je
crois que c'est une manière d'attribuer
ils sont deux théories du complot c'est
à dire si didier rahout n'a pas fait des
essais en double aveugle randomisée etc
ce ne serait pas parce que on est en
situation de crise et qu en situation de
crise et d'urgence
on soigne les gens avant de se
préoccuper de la recherche fondamentale
ce ne serait pas pour ça alors que moi
je crois que c'est pour ça c'est à dire
qu'il ya la crise il ya le temps de la
crise le temps d'urgence et il ya le
temps de la recherche fondamentale qui
est sûre qui est un autre rythme et moi
je suis d'accord
pour que les deux à les deux
fonctionnent et que ne soit pas
exclusifs l'un de l'autre mais au lieu
de d'imaginer cela on projette sur
didier raoult justement une sorte
d'intentionnalité maligne et à quel
intérêt puisque vous me dites que c'est
ce que vous dites vous dites il n'a pas
voulu parce que ça aurait prouvé que
donc pourquoi s'est-il attaché au temps
à l'hydre chloroquine pourquoi alors que
ça ne marche pas mais il veut absolument
le prouver donc il a une intentionnalité
malines il fait prendre un risque aux
gens qu'ils soient qui soit dit en
passant sont et le lot l'opinion des
patients je veux dire des patients qui
se sont fait soigner quand même
important jusqu'à preuve du contraire ce
capable contre un gars non seulement
aucun procès de la part des patients et
je crois que tous les médecins de france
et de navarre ne peuvent pas en dire
autant
il n'y a pas de procès contre didier
rahout aujourd'hui à marseille ce n'est
pas parce que les marseillais sont plus
stupide que les eaux parce qu'ils ont
quand même eu le sentiment d'être
soignés et ceux qui ont été touchés
ils l'ont ressentir au premier degré
mais moi ce que je ne comprends pas
c'est comment
quel peut être l'intérêt de didier
rahout à dire qu'est ce que c'est cette
théorie du complot qui suppose que
l'entêtement de didier rahout serait
politique c'est à dire que le
l'hydrochlorothiazide serait une une
arme politique pour didier raoult
pourquoi pour qu'il devienne maire de
marseille pour être élu président de la
république pour obtenir le prix nobel
mais il va pas obtenir le prix nobel
justement si vous dites si vous en être
sûr que les essais qui seront ultra
sérieux par la suite vont montrer que ça
ne marche pas il est sûr à ce moment là
d'aller dans le mur et ne pas obtenir le
prix nobel
donc c'est qu'il est il est en train de
dire i les théories du complot
intentionnalité et en plus il est
complètement idiot parce que comme ça va
ça va se révéler être faux eh bien il va
se planter
donc il faut savoir soit c'est un type
qui est extrêmement intelligent qui est
dans la théorie du complot
soit c'est un type qui complètement
idiot vous voulez qu'ils soient les deux
en même temps c'est pas compatible
c'est juste ma compatibles donc je ne
comprends pas cet acharnement justement
à vouloir politiser le discours de
djaout qui se comportent juste comme un
médecin en temps de crise en situation
d'urgence
et jusqu'à preuve du contraire les
patients qui la soignaient qui sont
quand même massif en termes de nombre
ils sont ils sont assez contents que
c'est pas mal
olivier berruyer il a tué personne
ali a chuté à 75 places vous me
contredisez pas oui tu as fait 75 6 il
ya 36 morts oui tout attaquer aux ragots
a fini par le dire je n'interviens pas
non mais voilà c'est tout je vous disais
il ya 36 morts soit 75 lits tentés 36
déjà ils ont pas l'air très content du
nam bô mais voilà après après vous voyez
dans ce deuxième fois je vous ai je vous
dis non il ya 75 lits dans 75 lits qui
sont considérés comme des
l'hospitalisation en situation d'urgence
de gens qui doivent rentrer dans des
danses elie justement parce qu'à des
conditions très spécifiques vous le
savez ça coûte très très cher parce que
les conditions d'hygiène très
particulière pour gérer un malade dans
les chu dans un lit alia chu donc les
maladresses très peu de temps ils font
la suite il ya le soin de suite ensuite
s'effectue à dents dans l'ensemble de
l'ap-hm à la timone et parfois même dans
d'autres hôpitaux avec un suivi ou
parfois même lire les gens rentrent chez
eux donc le les 75 10 et un lieu c'est
un lieu de passage
en fait il ya eu des milliers de gens
traités qui sont passés depuis le début
depuis le début de la crise 75 dit c'est
juste d'être un lieu de passage
d'urgence et de et de 2,2 comment dire
de cas extrêmes justement da costa s'est
passé par les passages la plupart des
gens qui ont été traités ils allaient
3000 sont pas tous et hospitalisé j'ai
assez des gens qui sont en ambulatoire
en les boissons minutes on peut les
questions façon il n'avait rien quand on
quand on regardait comme un comme
symptômes ils sont rentrés chez eux
mêmes des as automatique d'en payer il
ya 36 morts alors et intense qu'elle a
donnée nous le nombre de spécialisation
qui a eu avant que les gens meurent
c'est intéressant car le ration ce que
vous aimez bien les ratios vous savez
cette variante donc les petites
manipulations statistiques on les fait
pas trop mais je pardonne mais je suis
bien de santé ne suis pas statisticiens
moi je ne suis pas statisticiens je ne
connais pas les chiffres exacts mais je
sais que jusque jusque là et jusqu'à
preuve du contraire il n'y a pas eu de
2,2 plein d'individus qui ont été
mécontents par le traitement et la lah
les morts jusqu'à maintenant qu'ils ont
qui on est et ont été comptabilisés moi
j'ai encore une fois je ne suis pas
médecin mais on verra
in fine et ce ne serait pas ce ne sont
pas des morts jusqu'à preuve du
contraire qui
ont dû à l'application du traitement
mais c'est ce qu'on appelle la
comorbidité puis toute une série de
toute une série de choses ce qui compte
puisque vous êtes ça titille siens ce
qui compte c'est ce qui compte et à la
fin ça nous regarderons c'est par nombre
de personnes traitées pas seulement
hospitalisés dans les landes en alliage
parce que justement il passe en
situation d'urgence lorsque ces intenses
lorsqu'ils sont en situation de crise et
après on laisse la place à quelqu'un
d'autre
ce qui sera important de savoir c'est
sur l'ensemble des personnes traitées
qui peuvent avoir été hospitalisé ou qui
peuvent ne pas avoir été hospitalisé
sylla l'intensité de la maladie ne ne
nécessitait pas obligatoirement le
nécessitait pas d'hospitalisation savoie
quels sont justement les ratios
statistiquement en terme de mortalité
d'aggravation ou de gens qui sont sortis
il n'y a que ça qui va nous donner des
informations et les informations on les
aura donc vous ne pouvez pas dire on
n'hésite pas on les aura forcément
alors on a cru mais je crois que nous
devons plutôt al'avantage de iasi et
pour l'instant mais bon je vous
interromps vous de contraire une seconde
tous les deux on a cru les avoir ces
informations quand the land cette
prestigieuse revue scientifique a publié
une étude qui donnait plutôt raison à
votre travail critique olivier berruyer
puisque il y était dit que en regardant
rétrospectivement plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de malades qui avait été traité
un peu partout dans le monde on pouvait
en conclure du moins c'est ce que
conclut est cette étude publiée dans ce
land 7
on pouvait en conclure que non seulement
ce traitement n'était pas efficace mais
qu'en plus il était dangereux il
rajoutait de la mortalité et c'est
d'ailleurs à la suite de cette
publication que l' oms a dit qu'il
valait mieux pas le plus utilisé l'hydro
si chloroquine etc en france son usage a
été interdit en tant qu' en tant que
traitement et puis badaboum
le lendemain ou le surlendemain the
lands est lui-même rétropédale et met en
garde contre l'étude qu'il a publié deux
jours avant et on s'aperçoit ion
dit qu'il y aurait des données qui
auraient été falsifiés etc etc
comment comment l'expliquez-vous olivier
berruyer parce que vous avez dû lire
cette étude d'abi du vous dire bye
ils me donnent raison et puis deux jours
après bah non non non pas du tout aucun
moment moi j'ai pris position sur la
chloroquine j'en sais rien si ça marche
il ya une façon de savoir si un
médicament marche c'est ce qu'a dit
raphaël liogier c'est vous faites un
essai clinique randomisé en double
aveugle et là vous savez si ça marche et
si ça marche pas moi je n'ai jamais dit
sur mon site ça marche ou ça mange pas
peu dire les il ya des études qui disent
que ça marche alors que ce n'est pas
vrai car c'est ça le problème ravoux
c'est je ne dis pas calculant qui ne
marche pas je dis que quand on vous dit
je sais que ça marche et ça il le fait
des mois février
kirène mois de février vient dire que
c'est bon on a trouvé le remède est le
co beats avec la fonction respiratoire
la plus facile à traiter je reprends ses
mots on est à quatre cent mille morts et
toujours pas créés tu mens il y aura
peut-être pas de traitement bien c'est
ça aussi que les gens ne sont pas prêts
à accepter y aura peut-être jamais de
traitement médicamenteux contre ce truc
là parce que généralement les maladies à
virus
il n'y a pas des traitements il ya pas
traitement contre la rougeole contre la
rubéole contre la grippe ça n'existe pas
donc il sait pas évident qu'il ya un
traitement
simplement quand j'ai vu le 27 pour en
revenir oui bon on a vu que tu as on le
lance les conclusions du 27 aller dans
le sens de cinq ou six études
précédentes si vous voulez s'était pas
t'es pas une révélation mais en effet sa
puissance statistique était intéressante
pour avoir un début de réponse
elle concluait des teneurs en sept ans
dix ans maintenant c'est pas sûr il faut
faire un essai clinique randomisé en
double aveugle n'était pas affirmatif
sur ce point là donc l'emballement même
politique et qui a eu soit tu des landes
set a été très étonnante
mais oui ça c'est une preuve qu'il ya
fraude en sciences bien sûr et c'est
pour ça qu'il ya de la zététique c'est
pour ça qu'il ya des chasseurs de
fraudeurs je pense que je suis pas
contre raout moi je prendrais mon bep
sion c'est à dire c'est aussi
dégueulasse ce café mais rask a fait 27
que la mauvaise science de chez de
sherwood
donc il faut vraiment s'organiser et il
faut sans doute faire des réformes
importantes sur un bas sur les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques pompiers
mois de lobbying à ce niveau là sur la
recherche publique sur la publication
des données
je vais pas m'étendre il ya beaucoup de
choses à faire enfin liogier après le
rebondissement ultime sur l'étude 2
hollande 7 contre laquelle the lands est
lui même nous mettons en garde le
conclusion en avez-vous tiré à part le
fait que c'est on est toujours dans
l'ordre de la croyance qu'on soit pour
ou contre
didier raoul tu sais c'est passionnel et
c'est aveugle ah oui là on est amis là
on est dans des essais mais aveugle a
effectivement des conclusions aveugle
mais même si même si effectivement le le
le l'article du land 7 comme du new
england journal of medecine qui sont les
deux grands journaux médicaux qui ont
repris les mêmes que repris les mêmes
informations ne sont pas absolument
conclusif moi ce que je trouve ce que je
trouve fascinant et là je serais
d'accord mon interlocuteur c'est la
politisation qui a eu et une
politisation là je j'imagine que vous
serez d'accord de dire comment se
fait-il que à la seule publication à la
seule publication déjà d'un article en
dehors du scandale que représente cette
représente l'article lui-même qu'à la
seule publication il ya eu une réaction
si direct presque réactive de l' oms et
du gouvernement français mais je trouve
que là c'est pas sérieux du tout aux
critiques raout sur ces réactions
intempestives et là je crois que c'était
intempestif au sens du mot intempestifs
c'est à dire que c'était extrêmement
rapide comme s'il fallait tout de suite
là réagir réagir immédiatement ça c'est
le premier point parce que là la
politisation elle est vraiment réel
elle est vraiment belle est le 2 le 2 le
deuxième point ces scandales il faut
quand même à paraître aujourd'hui parce
que et c'est au delà de la question de
la chloroquine au-delà de la question
polémique de raout les pour les contre
tous et toutes ces choses là font
apparaître qu'aujourd'hui la recherche
en médecine en particulier il y a des
problèmes aujourd'hui dans la recherche
en médecine dans le bâtiment dire dans
les liens le financement des
laboratoires parce qu'on sait que c'est
en partie via sa les les
les erreurs qu'elle dire que ça a été
financé pour aller plus vite
pour pouvoir impressionner justement
puisqu'on parle de statistiques
impressionné en ayant des échantillons
statistiques extrêmement vaste en les
traitant via la l'intelligence
artificielle via une start up dont on ne
sait plus très bien aujourd'hui cette
start-up si elle est sérieuse si elles
existent si elle existe vraiment si elle
existe vraiment depuis si longtemps ce
qu'elle a fait comment elle l'a fait on
a découvert petit à petit que même dans
le les les hôpitaux australien on
n'avait pas donné les chiffres qu'on
prétend que l'étude prétend avoir eu y
avait même eu des erreurs avec je crois
un hôpital asiatiques étaient comptés
parmi les autres arrières passe été
imaginé imaginez en sens inverse quand
même juste une seconde ce qui se serait
passé on a vu ce qui s'est passé là
quand imaginer ce qui se serait passé si
une telle erreur de dire vraiment un tel
scandale était arrivé dans le cadre de
la gestion de crise des idées choix qu'a
pu faire au public a pu faire didier
rahout dans son cachet mais là il serait
littéralement crucifié
parce que là vraiment leu leu leu
vraiment vite et l'article l'article du
passé c'est quasiment jamais arrivé je
sais pas je parle sous votre contrôle
moi j'avais jamais vu en tout cas dans
le lancet qui avait déjà eu d'aidé mais
même le du rédacteur en chef du lancet
qui avait déjà fait son autocritique sur
certains certains articles
mais à ce point ce n'était jamais arrivé
c'est quand même une remise en cause de
la de la crédibilité du du journal
scientifique médical le plus prestigieux
au monde celui qui est supposé
représenter le plus de garanties je vous
dis avec le new england journal of
medecine qui a suivi c'est quand même
c'est quand même extraordinaire c'est
quand même vraiment extraordinaire il
faut savoir qu'il ya quand même eu déjà
des rétractations de la part des grands
journaux comme comme seul en 7
et comme le disait olivier berruyer tout
à l'heure il ya de plus en plus de
falsification je me souviens de
livres qui ont traité de ce phénomène
qui s'amplifie 1 chaque année puisque
les chercheurs sont obligées de publier
pour justifier l'argent qu'ils demandent
donc on publie de plus en plus vite et
parfois on truc un peu les données pour
se donner raison
néanmoins une une rétractation
parce que c'est comme la wii oui oui je
vous en prie en la science c'est encore
plus prégnant parce que c'est pas
seulement publié pour publier comme nous
en sciences humaines par exemple c'est
parce que il faut absolument publiée
tout de suite parce que ça a été
financée par un laboratoire qui veut des
résultats tout de suite pour ensuite
pouvoir aller le plus vite dans la
commercialisation de son de son
médicament je crois que ça c'est c'est
vraiment un indéniable alors je ne jette
la pierre à personne est dit là on a des
liens directs entre finances
laboratoires pharmaceutiques et
recherche dite fondamentale ça c'est
indéniable qu'est ce que vous en dites
livier berruyer parce que cette
accusation était récurrente pendant
toute la sphère didier raoul tu
l'accusation contre la big pharma
l'industrie pharmaceutique et ses liens
avec un certain nombre de médecins qui
serait forcément en tira hoult monstre
ou c'est une affaire assez assez triste
évidemment qu'il ya un problème de base
moi je suis pro big pharma c'est moi je
pense qu'il faudrait nationaliser sanofi
parce que c'est pas normal qu'on ait pas
un labo public pour produire les
médicaments je pense qu'il faudrait
interdire des rémunérations des médecins
par les labos je pense qu'il faut
absolument un organisme public pour la
publication
donc voilà ça c'est vrai mais il ya des
problèmes aussi du côté public verra ce
que fait la chute de marseille un
contrat ou qui se met à signer 150 à 200
études par an alors qu un chercheur de
qualité il en fait sens dans une vie
normalement parce qu'il fait rigoler les
américains sachant qu'à chaque fois
qu'une publications dans les revues des
collègues qui se sont organisées à
marseille
ces 600 euros il est qui tombe pour la
ph m au détriment des autres hôpitaux de
france dont il ya aussi un vrai problème
sur le financement public et sur cette
méthode là de financement qui a été très
fortement critiquée par la cour des
comptes
j'ose espérer que le gouvernement
réagira sur ce point là
mais voilà oui il ya un problème et il
faut le traiter
maintenant je trouve regrettable cet
aspect qui consiste à dire oui mais tout
médecin est qu'il ya une situation de
conflit d'intérêts c'est un une
ordure qu'il faut pas qu'il faut pas
écouter je répète j'aime pas ce système
mais peut pas conclure ça dans le
conflit d'intérêts sa montre qu' il faut
faire plus attention à ce cas contre la
personne puisqu'elle a un conflit
d'intérêt ça veut pas dire que ce que
racontent ces forts et et de conflits
d'intérêts il n'est pas que financier il
ya aussi de conflit d'intérêt il y
ajoute marcel c'est évident mais
monsieur raphaël logique et qui essayent
de milliards qui aurait aucun problème à
ce que vient de dire tard je me suis
trompé j'ai traité 3000 marseillais pour
rien ça marche pas du tout la
chloroquine c'est vrai que ça va être
très intéressant dans quelques mois ci
et là ce qui vient hélas c'est la vérité
scientifique conclut sa donc en conclure
qu'il n'y ait pas en trouver de
on conclure je sais pas comme l'a fait
tout à l'heure messieurs logis et que tu
as mais quand sanofi dit que la
chloroquine ça marche pas à temps c'est
peut-être c'est peut-être 6,6 à ce que
je pense que vous avez dit vous avez dit
que quand la question quand même le labo
dit mon médicament ne marche pas pour
essayer de vous en sortir
bien que le raisonnement normale
c'est-à-dire pas donc ça marche pas
gérer non mais ils ont peut-être un
médicament caché qu'ils vont vendre
encore plus cher donc les tipis préfère
qu'on crève
sans traitement dire c'est ça vient
c'est sale comme raisonnement
y'a qu'un philosophe puisse penser ça
puis sensu fait ça dans la population
dense avec la population va j'ai en main
facilement à ce genre de truc choquant
moi je trouve ça très chaud qu'en gros
on repassera l'extrait j'ai pas de souci
c'est exactement ce que vous avez dit et
il me revient sur les strokes a pas de
souci non plus mais c'est ce qui est
c'est la petite chanson quand même âge
qui partirent toi donc oui bah a très
bien je l'assumé bien fuir rapporte ne
dit pas peu importe donc ne dit pas papa
mais qu'est ce qu'ils apportent j'ai pas
compris votre évier excusez moi et je
vous vois sourire mais je peux appeler
moi je trouve que c'est important ce que
vous voulez dire que vous avez fait quoi
le star il dit est important donc je
veux comment ont terminé olivier de
tamines et olivier berruyer puis vous
avez la parole l'émission se termine et
reste trois minutes donc il faut trouver
le juste milieu bien sûr qu'il faut
douter bien sûr qu'il ya des conflits
d'intérêts bien sûr qu'il faut faire
attention mais après science met à vivre
dans un monde aux grands s'imagine que
tout le monde on est entouré de
qu'ils nous disent pas la vérité qui
enfin il ya quand je pense au nombre de
médecins qui se sont défoncés partout en
france qu'on essaie de faire croire qu'à
que raoult qui arrive en médecine de
guerre moi j'essaye mais tous les
médecins on va essayer moi enfin la
salpêtrière et dossier la chloroquine
dès le début puisque les chinois
utilisent et gèrent j'ai parlé avec les
médecins la salpêtrière il n'y a pas que
ça il n'y a pas que moi ou qu'il fait
acquis qui fait s'agir tous les médecins
se sont défoncés que vous avez 15 à 20 %
du corps médical qui est chopé le co
leader cédé 1 euro ces gens là essayer
de les faire passer tous il y en a
quelques-uns mais tous pour des espèces
d'ordures de jean vendu à les cultiver
cette espèce de moi j'aime pas le mot
populisme cette espèce de deux musiciens
10,1 dans les sondages non mais beaucoup
l'ont dit ses pièces vous l'avez pas dit
ça ça vous l'avez pas dit vous mais
beaucoup l'ont dit dans cette frange de
penser
moi je trouve ça je vois pas comment on
peut construire un monde propre si on a
ce schéma de pensée là et si en plus on
nagera dès vérité différente on n'arrive
plus à se mettre d'accord sur des faits
élémentaires
alors que la science permet de faire ça
donc enfin je peux répondre alors alors
premièrement mois / / / sanofi je n'ai
absolument pas dit que c'était des
ordures qu'ils voulaient sacrifier la
vie des gens profitent etc
je dis seulement que quand vous avez eu
deux voulu donner comme argument de la
chloroquine ça ne marche pas la preuve
vous avez 10 à nos fils dit je dis c'est
pas du tout un argument qu'un
laboratoire vous disent que ça marche ou
ça ne marche pas même si c'est ce
laboratoire qui fabrique qui fabrique le
qui fabrique ce médicament c'est juste
ça ce que j'ai voulu dire parce que moi
je ne suis pas du tout dans la théorie
du complot et je ne suis pas du tout
pour lui sur l'idée qu'il ya un monde
d'ordures je crois qu'il y a des
intérêts mais des intérêts qui sont
multiples et variables on à l'intérêt de
se faire soigner intérêt à être heureux
intérêts parfois à gagner de l'argent et
tout ça est très complexe et multiple je
ne crois pas à une intentionnalité
maligne donc ensuite donc en tant que ce
n'était pas un argument pour en sens
inverse c'était juste pour dire c'est
pas une preuve que vous avancez en
disant c'est parce que ça nous sur 10 la
preuve de lacunes c'est juste ça nommé
juge les mêmes je suis même d'accord
avec vous là dessus vous voulez je vous
le dis mais moi je crois que les laits
je crois qu'en revanche les études
internationales sur en situation de
il en situation de pandémie sur un temps
long eh bien ce sont des insultes en
cours pardon excusez moi sont sont ou
seront pas du tout incompatible avec les
essais en vol
et contrairement à ce que vous dites ne
ralentissent pas la recherche mais en ce
qui concerne en ce qui concerne les les
articles le nombre important d'articles
du d'hédiard où je vous signale que
c'est ce qui se pratique aussi ça fait
pétrir des américains mais moi je suis
chercheur invité à columbia university
qui a une très très importante école
médicale de recherche médicale et je
vous assure que les pompes aussi sur
place qui sont vraiment les grands
chercheurs
eh bien ils mettent aussi leur nom à
plusieurs sur sur sur les articles sont
publiés énormément ensuite l'argent il
ne va pas à l'ap-hm il va à la fondation
de l'ia chu est une forme wii est donc
c'est pas la ph nc magra l'ap-hp qui va
dans les poches des raouts ni dans les
poches
nominalement pour soi la bhl pour
continuer à baisser dans la fondation
save à la fondation
non c'est pas sympa ce financement
direct en tout cas c'est ce qu'a dit à
juin mais toute façon vous ne publiez
pas les comptes vous ne publiez rien sur
vos chiffres ceux votre site internet
donc n'en sais rien mais moi j'ai fait
un super représentants à d'année en
année au nom mais selon moi je ne suis
pas représentants du tout de lien je ne
connais pas les courbes de 6h et je suis
content d'université à edge et en
sciences humaines
je ne veux et je suis membre du comité
de suivi éthique et ma ma position
s'arrête à cela et pas plus que cela
les cinq démissions cette émission va
s'arrêter je vous proposent chacun un
petit mot de conclusion
s'ils tentaient qu'on peut conclure sur
une affaire telle que celle ci il y aura
certainement d'autres rebondissements
olivier berruyer sur cette affaire
didier raoul tu tu n'as fait un peu
particulière puisque d'habitude près des
mails ou avoir des médecins qui essayent
de tromper les autres médecins et
scientifiques là là on a je vous dit
quelqu'un qui agace sortie qui s'est
plus préoccupé de ce que pensent les
autres scientifiques de son travail pour
essayer d'avoir l'opinion de son côté il
a plutôt bien réussi deux de ce côté là
le savez cette méthode de raout ce que
cette méthode raul7 cette espèce de
refus de la méthode scientifique
ça rien de novateur c'est ce qu'on
faisait avant c'est la vaccine de
molière versées aux tiens il ya le pot
vide qui arrive à saigner pour tout le
monde
testons mais surtout surtout faisons pas
de groupe entre ce conseil est ce qu'on
saigne pas puisque toute façon ça fait
200 ans qu'on fait de la saignée donc
évidemment choqués par le sort et bien
c'est exactement ça cette méthode c'est
la méthode du refus de la science c'est
la méthode du refus de la preuve et sait
gérer la met le refus du respect du
patient qui n'est pas je répète encore
un cobaye réponse de même en guerre
raphaël liogier c'est marrant parce que
moi je dirais que je trouve que c'est
exactement dans un sens et
symétriquement contraire c'est
symétriquement contraire c'est à dire
que le fait d'offrir aux patients une
stratégie une stratégie qui ne se veut
pas un falsifiable c'est pragmatique
c'est rationnel et pragmatique c'est
pragmatique par sts au rationnel et s'il
y avait justement d aggravation et bien
ça s'arrêterait s'il y avait c'est à
dire ça s'arrêterait par l'observation
dans la relation du médecin avec le
patient
lorsqu'on est à des lorsqu'on est à des
échelles vous dit sur des options sur
des sur des milliers de patients alors
que dans ce sens inverse
le problème de 2 des essais randomisés
qui cherche le le médicament pur le
médicament absolue comme vous l'avez dit
vous-même qu'on ne trouvera peut-être
jamais et bien c'est quand en attendant
pas qu'on n'a pas prouvé le médicament
parfait le médicament est falsifiable en
quelques en quelque sort eh bien on
sacrifie la population sacrifie la
population profite d'une sorte pour
appeler je sais pas moi de de théologie
positiviste d'idées qu'il faut trouver
absolument le médicament qui correspond
mais sans aller jusqu'à molière parce
que là c'est un faux procès d'entendre
ce que à l'époque de molière c'était
quasiment justement de la magie 1
c'est justement le la médecine n'est pas
une science pas mes autres c'est une
science qui suppose le ce qu'on appelle
le colloque singulier c'est à dire une
relation particulière avec le patient et
donkey et évolutive c'est effectivement
ça que pratique didier rahout sans pour
autant être être opposé à la halle à la
science fondamentale
merci tous les deux alors participer à
ce débat ça valait vraiment la peine
d'attendre
ne pas faire le débat sur la sphère out
dès le début comme l'ont fait les autres
mais la tendre jusqu'à maintenant merci
de nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]